welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king and mike floria are talking about
some of the biggest issues in the nfl
and a huge game coming up on sunday
night peter on nbc the philadelphia
eagles traveling to dallas for their
first of two games this year against the
cowboys both teams are three and three
and the loser of this game is going to
have a hard uh path to the postseason
especially because those wild card teams
likely coming from the other divisions
which team is in more trouble between
the eagles and the cowboys going into
this one
dallas mike i think there is such a
churn around so many things right now in
dallas number one jason garrett
everybody is talking about it jerry
jones talks about it steven jones
everybody is talking about his job
status uh it just never ends that has to
be just
so tiring for everybody associated with
that team but more importantly
this week you've still got both tackles
even if tyron smith leo collins do play
they're not going to be near 100
and it's looking more and more like
amari cooper is not going to play again
so that's another weapon for dak
prescott against a premier pass rush
that he's going to be without mike i
think dallas is in big trouble
yeah amari cooper exited early on sunday
night with that quad injury and his
status for sunday's up in the air if one
or both tackles can't play it's gonna be
harder for the cowboys office to get
going and the problem for the cowboys
peter has been they fall behind and they
are not built to play from behind they
are built to to build a lead and
continue to build it and then suffocate
you with that running game and pass off
of it to deliver the dagger once they're
up seven or ten points and i think part
of the problem for the cowboys the
expectations were so high coming into
the season and then they win three in a
row to push that that bar even higher
and it's been a huge disappointment to
lose three in a row i think you know
between the two teams the eagles have to
feel better about being three and three
than the cowboys do because once the
cowboys started 3-0 we thought they were
going to be five and one at a minimum
through six games
one of the reasons why i didn't pick the
cowboys to make the playoffs before the
year mike is that i didn't like their
depth and look in the first three four
weeks of the year
uh dak prescott played a lot better than
i thought he would but he's sort of
regressing to the mean the last couple
weeks
and i i still think there's great
question about whether he can be a top
five quarterback he certainly is not
look like one particularly when he is
flushed out of the pocket as much as
he's been but i think the other thing
about this team that has become
worrisome mike that we did not think at
the beginning of the year we thought
there was going to be enough pass rush
to maybe mask a few deficiencies in that
secondary but that secondary has been
burned a lot sam darnold steps out of
the uh
you know basically out of sick bay and
he comes and he throws a a 92-yard pass
to robbie anderson to basically start
this very very bad day for the cowboys
and look that secondary just has to be
better but that's what you can say about
a lot of elements of this dallas team
well and the eagles have been racked
with injuries as well their secondary
has been banged up they're hoping to get
some guys healthy and they've been
missing receiver desean jackson since
week one he had a huge impact they were
down 17 to nothing and carson wentz told
me after that game once he hit desean
jackson everything changed jackson has
barely played since then he's got an
abdominal injury apparently it's some
sort of a of a small tear in his groin
the sooner he gets back the quicker the
eagles can turn this around and open up
their offense i mean the great irony for
the eagles has been the guy we always
worry about carson wentz getting injured
he's been healthy all year it's the guys
around him that aren't holding up and i
think between the two i have more faith
actually in the eagles getting it right
and moving forward especially once they
get jackson back peter
i do too i like the eagles a little bit
better right now mike but you talk about
desean jackson anybody who takes a and i
don't know how old he is what is he 32
33
anybody who takes a speed merchant
thin is a rail guy and expects him who's
had some injury issues and expects him
to stay healthy at that age it's just
it's a pipe dream so whatever you get
out of him i thought at the beginning of
the year whatever you got out of him was
a bonus they may have already gotten
everything they could get salvaging one
game for them in the early season so
it's probably worth it just for that but
i wouldn't expect much out of him mike
meanwhile cowboys and eagles are three
and three giants are two and four
they're going to watch this one closely
as well we'll see you for more pft ot
throughout the nfl season
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports